[Music]
in ursula kayla green's fourth earth sea
novel to hanu one of the key themes that
runs throughout the entire work is that
of teaching and learning
tenar has to determine what kind of
things young pharaoh the maimed and
abused child ought to be taught what
things she ought to learn and
who should be doing the teaching
and how and it's not just the challenge
that faces
every
parent
what to do with their children how to
prepare them for life
in this case tenor has been given a
charge by her old teacher and
in effect parent
ogian the mage and as he
is on his way
towards death
he tells her about
theru
that she has to
do something and it sends everybody away
when little thera woke he spoke to her
in the kind dry quiet way tenna
remembered the child went out to play in
the sun and he said to tenor what is the
name you call her
he knew the true language of the making
but he'd never learned any carcass at
all theroux means burning the flaming of
fire she said ah
he said in his eyes gleamed and he
frowned he seemed to grope for words for
a moment and now he says two really
important things
that one he said that one they will fear
her
they fear her now tenor said bitterly
the mage shook his head so he's giving a
kind of you know prognostication or
prophecy about the fear that people are
going to feel
in relation to thera that that is not
the fear simply of a maimed burned child
that perhaps it's you know
not just evil has been done to it but
but it is evil
rather
it's about what's going to happen when
thiru does
in fact come into her power although
tenor doesn't doesn't get that at that
point in time
then he says teacher tenor teach her all
not roke they are afraid why did i let
you go why did you go to bring her here
too late
meaning that ogien himself would have
taken part in teaching
young pharaoh and he's saying not rogue
what does that actually mean well roque
is this island where the high arts are
being taught we'll get an interpretation
of that a little bit later from beach
which will actually let's take a look at
that right now because it's a what we
could call a rather facile
interpretation it's it's not one
that
you know we
ought to have any credence and so
tenor says ogean told me to teach her
teach her all he said and then not roke
i don't know what he meant beech had no
difficulty with it he meant that the
learning of rock the high arts wouldn't
be suitable for a girl
let alone one so handicapped but if he
said to teach her all but that lore
it would seem that he too saw her way
might well be the witch's way he
pondered again more cheerfully having
gotten the weight of ojin's opinion on
his side in a year or two when she's
quite strong and grown a bit more you
might think about asking ivy to begin
teaching her a bit not too much of
course even that of that kind of thing
till she still has her true name and
tenar feels a strong immediate
resistance to the suggestion she says
nothing because beech is a sensitive man
so this is probably not the right
interpretation we're getting right but
what is the right interpretation it's
going to be much more
simple and much more
complex than that so we've got these
these two things they will fear her
teach her all don't teach her rock or
don't teach her at rogue and then we
have a number of different occasions
where teaching comes up
one of the first ones has to do with
the witch auntie moss
and we find that
here we go
moss got on with the burn child perhaps
it was moss who was working this change
this slight easing and thero with her
thero behaved as with everyone else
blank unanswering docile in the way an
inanimate thing a stone is docile but
the old woman had kept at her offering
her little sweets and treasures bribing
coaxing weedling come with auntie moss
now deary come along and auntie moss
will show you the prettiest sight you
ever saw
and um she says she took the child into
the fields and showed her a lark's nest
in the green hay or into the marshes to
gather white hallows wild mint and
blueberries she did not have to shut the
child in an oven or change her into a
monster or sealer and stone that had
been done already those are the things
witches were supposed to do
she was kind to theory but it was a
weedling kindness and when they were
together it seemed she talked to the
child a great deal tenor
did not know what moaz was telling or
teaching her whether she should let the
witch fill the child's head with stuff
and as they go on um in in the thing um
watching moss with theroux now she
thought moss was following her heart but
it was a wild dark queer heart like a
crow going its own ways on its own
errands and she thought moss might be
drawn to thiru not only by kindness but
by thera's hurt by the harm that had
been done to her by violence by fire so
she's thinking there's something not
quite right
about this or something that needs to be
watched but then she says
nothing theroux did or said showed she
was learning anything from auntie moss
except where the lark nested and the
blueberries grew and how to make cat's
cradles one
handed
and tenor thought what bond linked her
herself to the child beyond pity mere
duty to the to the helpless
so you know
it's okay for moss to teach her in part
because thero is just learning
bits and pieces of things she's not
learning a way of life she's not
learning
moss's perspective so much
a little bit later um
there's some ideas about maybe
apprenticing there
uh we'll talk about the which one in
just a moment but first there's an idea
about perhaps apprenticing her to
fan the weaver
and
theroux is thinking to her tenor is
thinking to herself
tenor thought of thera sitting at that
loom it would be a decent living the
bulk of the work was dull always the
same over but weaving was an honorable
trade and in some hands a noble art and
people expected weavers to be a bit shy
often to be unmarried shut away at their
work as they were yet they were
respected and working indoors at a loom
thera would not have to show her face
but the claw hand could that hand throw
the shuttle warp the loom and was she to
hide all her life but what was she to do
knowing what her life must be
so
on the way
uh tenor is thinking about these things
and then when she finds
theroux missing she thinks to herself
this is my
penalty
for
having these thoughts
she said um
this was her fault that she had caused
it to happen by thinking of making thera
into a weaver shutting her away in the
dark to work to be respectable when
ogeon had said
teacher teach her all tenor
and here's a very important line
when she knew that a wrong that cannot
be repaired
must be transcended
when she knew that the child had been
given her and she'd failed in her charge
failed her trust lost her lost the one
great gift
daru is special
tenner is supposed to teach her it's not
just her you got instinct telling her
this but her own teacher who says you
need to teach her all not just find an
occupation a vocation for her that's
going to be safe and in some respects
the easy way out you need to embrace
this difficulty then there's ivy the
witch and after this conversation with
beech
she takes she goes to ivy and she says
um
listen i would like to talk to you
about um prenticing thero for a witch
when she's a bit older and ivy says well
i wouldn't take her
and there's already some some
bad blood some background between 10r
and ivy
ivy like most of the women you know in
in the vicinity thinks that tenor has
been a bit too
um
you know
uppity has played off of her difference
being a former priestess being the mage
of ogeon
and tenner thinks yeah actually there's
something to that i'd better start you
know mending bridges with ivy and so she
talks with ivy and she says well why why
not you know what what do you have
against thera and she says
she's a child an
illustr gets angry and says that's not
all she is
must apprentice witch be a virgin and
ivy says that's not what i mean
so here we get a really interesting
discussion that bears on who thero is
but also bears on what kind of education
she should receive
ivy says this
i don't know what she is when she looks
at me with that one eye seeing and one
eye blind i don't know what she sees
i see you go about with her like she was
any child and i think what are they
what is the strength of that woman for
she's not a fool to hold a fire by the
hand to spin thread with a whirlwind
they say mistress that you lived as a
child yourself with the old ones the
dark ones the ones underfoot and that
you were queen and servants of those
powers maybe that's why you're not
afraid of this one
what power she is i don't know
but it's beyond my teaching i know that
or beaches or any witch or wizard i ever
knew
i give you my advice beware her the day
she finds her strength that's all and
tenor is still angry she says nobody
would help her she thought she knew the
job was beyond her they didn't have to
tell her that but none of them would
help her ogean had died and old moths
ranted and ivy warned and beach kept
clear and ged the one who might really
have helped ged ran away
so you know she's feeling overwhelmed by
and perplexed by
this charge of teaching
theroux
and there's a point where she considers
to herself what she's actually
imparting to thera there's a very
important passage
uh where where this takes place
and she
thinks am i just giving her
um you know training in domestic things
here we go
um
theroux plays with with these what she
calls the
uh
the bone people you know
i should be teaching her tenor thought
to stress teach her all ojin said and
what am i teaching her cooking
and spinning
then another part of her mind said in
gohan's voice that's
her use name
are those not true arts needful and
noble is wisdom all words so you know
the the domestic thing i mean this is
actually a very important theme and that
ged will actually like clean up his own
plate and do things that uh
tenor's kind of spoiled sun
spark won't do because that's women's
work right
one of the messages in this is that
so-called women's work isn't really
women's work it's needful work and
cooking is an art and spinning is an art
all you got to do if you don't know
about these sorts of things is try your
hand at them for an hour and then a day
and find out just how
much
art is involved in cleaning for example
but is that what she should be teaching
thera
those are useful things but that's not
where it should end right a domestic
education
so she starts talking to her
she says it's maybe it's time you begin
to learn the true names of things
there's a language in which all things
bear their true names and deed and word
are one by speaking that tongue sugoi
raised up the islands from the deep it's
the language of the dragons speak the
child listens silent tenor laid down her
karting combs and picked up a small
stone from the ground in that tongue
this is tolk
you know the stone right
one that was used as an example in
wizard of earthsea by the way
that's the only word that tenor actually
teaches her in the old tongue and she
talks about that with ged later on
um she told them how she had taught
theory the one word and then it stopped
her it had not seemed right though she
did not know why now this is very
interesting right why why shouldn't she
go on and teach her more i thought
perhaps it was because i'd never truly
spoken that language never used it in
majory i thought perhaps she should
learn it from a true speaker of it ged
says well no no human being is a true
speaker of that
and he says the dragons only the dragons
speak it as their native tongue and then
tener says do they learn it and he he
was slow to answer calling to mind all
he had been told and knew of the dragons
i don't know what do we know about them
would they teach as we do mother to
child elder to younger or are they like
animals teaching some things but born
knowing most of what they know even that
we don't know but my guess would be the
dragon and the speech of the dragon are
one
one being they don't learn
they are
so you know this seems to be a bit of a
digression of course it's going to turn
out that perhaps
there doesn't need to be taught the old
speech so what what is she taught
instead
um tener says here's what i can do for
you
maybe when you have your true name i'll
teach you the the words not now now
listen now is the time for stories for
you to begin to learn the stories i can
tell you stories of the archipelago and
the kargish lands i told you a story i
learned from my friend i hall the silent
now i'll tell you when i learned from my
friend lark when she told it to her
children and mine this is the story of
andar and avad as long as forever as far
away as celador there lived a man called
andar and
it sort of tapers off here so she's
teaching her the lore of the land that
she
lives in which is still something quite
quite useful right
and
later on we're going to find that
she
the ethereum
is learning
uh some of the
great songs and can recite them together
she's learning them very quickly as well
she's a bright
kid and so until the radical
revelation that happens in the
last chapter of the work
this is the course of theru's education
as it's going to turn out perhaps some
of it is in fact
not needful or redundant but all of it
is an attempt for tenar to fulfill what
ogion is telling her she needs to do and
to do right by the child
you